اعلن حزب الله مهاجمه موقعين عسكريين
اسرائيليين قباله الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان
وقال الحزب ان مقاتليه استهدفوا تجمعا
لجنود الاحتلال في محيط ثكنه يعره وهاجموا
موقع حذب البستان مؤكدا تحقيق اصابات
مباشره وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان طائرات
الاحتلال شنت سلسله غارات على عده مناطق
جنوبيه لبنان وقال حزب الله ان ثلاثه من
مقاتليه استشهدوا في جنوب
البلاد في الاثناء قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان خمسه جنود اصيبوا بجروح
طفيفه بعد رصد عده عمليات لاطلاق السواريخ
من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه منطقه ادميت
في الجليل الغربي واضاف المتحدث ان سلاح
الجو شن سلسله غارات على مناطق متفرقه من
جنوب لبنان يرجح انها مراكز لاطلاق صواريخ
حزب الله نحو البلدات الحدوديه
الاسرائيليه كما قال انه تم تدمير مواقع
عسكريه وبنى تحتيه لحزب الله واستهداف
خليه بالقرب من قريه حوله حسب
تعبير